yeah like i'm a hustler i love money
like my name is cash for a reason
you can't stop me i'ma get money the way
i can and that's just me i'm 27 years
old
i'm young i have no kids and i'm gay
and i'm a pimp like it can't get no
better than that
sabrina yes sabrina where'd you grow up
where are you from originally
i am from compton california i grew up
in off of bradfield and rose krantz
i'm from mairu um
so you have a gang yes yes which gang is
this
mop that's a blood gang yes yep
tell me about your family growing up
okay so uh
my mom got pregnant at 13 years old and
my grandpa my grandma
put her out on the streets she when she
had me she gave me up
to my grandma and grandpa and they
raised me till i was two
my mom took me back she was introduced
into drugs
sherm acid myth whatever you know she
can get on her hands on
just so she can prostitute at the age of
13. um
well my family is i'm mexican puerto
rican and samoan
my family is the mexican side which
they're really strict i didn't know no
english until i
turned 13. so growing up it was hard
because i was
as dark as i am and my family believed
that i was black
but so they used to beat me they used to
make sure i spoke spanish they used to
try to scrub
the color off my skin and my mom took me
back when i was two
my mom told me back when i was two i
used to be with her
on the stroll the hostro all hours of
the day
all all the nights and you were old i
was two
two years old two years old your mom was
working figaro street figaro in long
beach long beach was her main one long
beach boulevard yes
um then my grandma took me back when i
was five years old
and um when i was eight my my
mom came and picked me up and told me
that she was trying to get out of the
game of the
prostitution game that her that she's
trying to get away from her pimp
and she had to tell me a bunch of stuff
so we parked in watts california
and she told me that she loved me to be
good for my grandma
and my family and that she's sorry and
everything will be okay two minutes
later she got out the car told me to lay
in the back seat
i actually got back up after she closed
the door
and i watched her get killed she got
shot 17 times by three pimps
i watched it all when i was eight years
old
um the ambulance and police came and
took me back to my family
and i was at a soccer game when they
finally gave us the news that she did
not make it
so you watched your mom get murdered yes
at eight years old
so at night so at nine years old what
street was this on
this was off of 108th and
i don't know the other street but it's
off 108th by gravestreet elementary
so um yeah so at nine years old my
grandfather came and moved in
i was i was
one day i was walking from from school
and when i walked into the house i saw
my grandfather
raping my melissa my cousin
and at that time my cousins you know i
grew up with them so i called them my
brothers and sisters
so at that time she was only four years
old and he was like
in this in the tub like rubbing on her
her
vagina area so i took it upon myself and
told him
to touch on me instead of touching on
her you know i was grown she wasn't i
know it wasn't right
but you know so i actually you're
protecting her
i protected her by putting myself in
danger
so it became more and more that he was
raping me molesting me
and all kinds of stuff and i tried to
one day we were at a party in my at my
house and he came in the garage drunk
and my cousins were and everybody were
in the garage
and he tried to get on top of me and and
do me in front of my cousins and i
called him all kind of [ __ ]
and he got mad so he went and told my
aunt that i called him a [ __ ]
so my aunt came and she started yelling
at me so i had to
i told her i'm like well he's raping me
and when i told her that she slapped
me and she told me that only
like we keep it in the family we don't
say things like that
and i told her i was like it wasn't
right you know i knew it wasn't right
so two days later i ran away
i ran away to a friend's house and
then like a day later my gran my grandma
found me
and she found me and took me back home
and
then after that she used to come and
pick me up after school and everything i
wasn't allowed to go to school by myself
anymore
and one day i found a way to um
to run away again and i did and they
didn't they didn't catch me
so this time my uncle came in to look
for me he
he came to look for me and he my friends
told me
where i was this was all
at 12 years old so he they told him how
um they told him i was he came and got
me
and took me to rancho from there i told
him where i was
and um that's why i told him everything
that happened and
he was so upset that he went back to the
house and
you know try to look for look for my
grandfather but he was gone my
grandfather knew what he did and he knew
you know the things that were going to
happen to him so he left i can't i went
back home
every day i was beat like because my
grandmother was mad that i got rid of my
grandfather
so in order to cope with it i joined the
gang
and you know i'm not a bad
i wasn't a bad kid i love school and all
that but in order for me to
deal with the gang and stuff and deal
with school and not be tired and stuff
i started doing math at 12 years old
and from there we went from meth powder
um a little bit of sherm here and there
and crack
so this is all at 12 years old then
foster care came
so they took me away and when they put
me in foster care i had a
nervous breakdown where i started biting
the foster mom
and when i started buying the foster mom
she took me to the mental hospital
where i was there for three months and
i was convinced that something was wrong
with me i didn't understand
nothing i only knew spanish like nobody
i
didn't have anybody to talk to me right
so i shut down i
became mute and i didn't speak at all
so finally i got into a foster home and
i lived all the way in pinyon hills
where it's like this is deserted it's
just one house and then nothing but
desert and then you have to drive
30 minutes to go to a store or anything
else another house or anything else
so living out there i
was able to find myself and like
meditate
and do other things and my foster mom
helped me
like you know get together she she was
been through
the same thing i've been through so it
was easier for me and her to connect
yes i became unmute but i did not speak
english still
because my foster mom was hispanic so
this whole time i'm going to school
don't know english but you know i'm
getting by
so at 15
at 15 i run away because
she started getting men in her house and
i wasn't comfortable with
it i'm not comfortable with hispanic men
not
being racist i'm just not it's just
uncomfortable for me
and i get nervous and i get very anxious
i get inside bad anxiety so
i run away and my social worker ended up
bringing me to
fontana so from fontana i was in a
foster home
and the foster mom lied to my f to my
social worker telling her
that there was no men that live in the
house when they're in fact where
was her trucker husband who was hispanic
so he was having relations with the
other foster daughters
and i wasn't okay with it so one day
when he tried to sneak into my room
i cussed him out and i the next visit
that i had with my family i let them
know
that i'm being like molested again and
they gave me a cell phone and told
me to call them when i needed them so
when that happened um he came into my
room again
and i called my family when that
happened i
he slapped me he slapped me because i
wouldn't give him my phone
and then he when he told his wife that i
was i had a cell phone and i was being
respectful and he heard the phone go off
and that he came to my room just so he
can get the phone because we're not
allowed a phone
so when that happened she came to look
for my phone and she couldn't find it
because i hid it in my jacket
so when they had left the next day i ran
away
i packed my things and i left i went to
my best friend's house and
i explained to him what was happening
and his mom allowed me to stay with her
they were african-american so i was
staying there
she while i was staying there i was
hidden mind you i'm awol
i'm i ran away from foster care my
social worker doesn't know where i'm at
there's a warrant out for my wrist and
i'm living with
another family and they're teaching me
english i'm teaching them spanish like
you know it's
i'm not on drugs no more she helps me
get back into high school
and everything's going great so but one
day um
we were caught at the store stealing and
um i got arrested i was arrested for
three months until my fa to my social
worker found me
and when my social worker found me she
sent me to a home in rancho manga
at that home the mother was a young and
she was she liked the club and she had
kids who were pimps and they had hoes
and they'll bring their
their the hoes will bring their kids to
me to watch them and i'll get paid for
that
so but as i'm watching the kids and
he's teaching me the game and like this
is what this is and you know
and i told him like i'm gay i like women
you know so he was just like well then
i'ma teach you the game
so you can become a pimp so he's giving
me
weed i'm we're smoking i'm back on drugs
now boom
started off a weed then he started doing
a little lean in it and then a little
crack
so from there i'm getting high as hell
and i'm still going to school i'm still
doing like you know
doing everything i'm supposed to until
one day my foster mom has gets a
boyfriend
and he's belgian and she goes to work
one day and he tries
to again sexually harass me because
i'm not giving him no play because i
told him i'm gay he doesn't believe
pretty women should be gay so therefore
he started trying to molest me i let her
know
she was unhappy with it so i one day i
asked her can i go to
my best friend's house for a halloween
party and she said yes
so i go when i go the buses are stopped
running
so the bus stopped running and i called
her and i let her know like okay can you
come get me because
you know the party's over she was just
like no you ran away you did this and
then like i don't want you back
so i called my social worker i let my
social worker know what's happening
and i go and i stay there so i'm getting
high because i'm worried that i'm going
to go back to jail and
like i'm crystalled out of my mind like
just so crystalled on my mind
so when i call myself show worker
the next day she tells me that it's okay
for me to stay where i'm at
so i stay there i go to high school i'm
in high school
and every day at this foster home i'm
fighting her daughter
every day like there was no it was a
constant goal like every day i wake up i
have to fight
every day this and that like it was so
it was so dramatic in that house
it was so uncomfortable for me to live
but yet i still did everything i was
supposed to i
made i went to work i went to school i
did everything i graduated a year before
i was supposed to graduate
and i was just working that whole year
so
i would pay rent i would do everything i
was supposed to watch the kids all that
and i grad when i graduated high school
i paid for all my my own
high school experience and after that
i went to college i got an aaa in
sociology
and i was sober for a little bit until
i got put out of the house and when i
put out the house i was forced to go
live with her daughter
when i went to go live with her daughter
her daughter um used me
just like a baby to the kids and so she
can get money off of me
and after that i just called my
my old foster brother and i told him
like i need money
i i'm i'm tired of just sitting here in
the house i'm tired of being broke i'm
tired of being
like bothered like this and i'm i want
money
so he took me to he took me out to san
bernardino off of g street
and he was like teaching me like telling
me like oh this is this and this
and back now i'm getting high again with
him
popping molly's popping e pills getting
high
and leaned out and just awake all night
all day
just so i can be able to learn the
routes so once i learned the routes
i com called my little friends that
liked me
and stuff on facebook and i let them
know like oh do you want to make extra
money this is this this is that
and so they were just like yeah so i go
pick them up
and i put them down money starts coming
in
i learned how to post them i post them
on craigslist backpage
redbook meet me all kind of
all kind of websites that i can put them
on just so i can make money and the
money was flowing in
and i got addicted so i started getting
addicted and
that's when i started pressing um
crystal hard
i started slamming it i started smoking
it started sniffing it whatever i can do
with crystal i did it i
uh cheated it up you know back there
and i just anything to get a high
so i can be okay with it you know and as
a woman
i couldn't be in the car it would be
suspicious so i used to dress as a
prostitute
and go down and you know be around the
girls and in order to stay warm
i had to do other drugs so i did crack
and
i was naked always naked and out there
and
just watching everything that goes down
collecting money selling drugs and
you know maneuvering so one day i got
kidnapped
i got kidnapped by a pimp named kelly in
pomona
california and he pistol with me
he took me to his house in la and
he was he tried to force me to hold for
him but
the thing is that he didn't want me to
hold he wanted me to steal
he didn't want me to sell myself he
wanted me to pretend
so he can still and i can steal from
them and he used to
he used to beat people like bloody
murdered and
i was like fighting for my life every
day like i used to
almost use the bathroom on myself number
two because
i was so scared like i was on the street
and he was parked right there like
there was nowhere for i can move like
you know
nothing so one day he got comfortable
after two weeks he got comfortable and
took me back to pomona
right when i got to pomona i called my
old foster brother and i'm like
look i'm here in pomona come get me he
comes and he gets me
so when he comes and gets me he asks me
like what happened and i'm telling him
like i'm describing the guy
describing the car and everything come
to find out that it's his cousin
his cousin saw me one day and he was
just like i want her
and i'm gonna do whatever i gotta do to
get her so when he finds out it's his
cousin they end up fighting the street
boom we all go to jail i go to jail
and i get relief and i go home to
compton california
and i started gang banging again and i
started really like
selling drugs and pimping and doing all
this kind of stuff
and to get money and my family started
disowning me
when they started disowning me i started
slang it to my family like i started
giving my family drugs and you know
doing it like that and
then um i started i started pimping
on my little sister she was 15 years old
and
she wanted to hold so i i had her
holding for me and you're hold up you're
how old now
me i was playing you went up at the time
you were 21 yes and she was she was
no i was 18 and she was 15. so
so we're i'm selling her me me my guy
friend
and her were thugging it then we started
getting more females
and my little sister runs away and she
doesn't come back she goes back home
and she's a pregnant and i'm still doing
me
then my other girl leaves me because she
got ran over by a car
and she felt like i didn't care so now
i'm here i'm slanging dope in the in the
riverbed i'm sleeping in tents
i'm cracked out of my mind i'm
like just so crystal out of my mind i'm
lit i'm going from garage to garage to
garage
and hotel to hotel to hotel 10 to 10 to
10
in all in norwalk riverbed by the
greenline station
so then one day my friend hits me up and
he's like oh i got a girl for you
so i go to southgate and i meet this
girl she tells me she's 18 years old at
this time i'm 21.
so she tells me she's 18 years old and
that she wants a whole
so we started doing it i got her hooked
on crystal meth
and so we're getting high as hell me and
her end up falling in love with each
other and
after we fall in love with each other
i'm like hey i don't want you homie no
more she's just like well this is the
only way to make you happy
so i'm going to go ahead and hold so
we're she's hoeing and we're doing this
whole thing
well one day i get pulled over by the
police and
they find my gun in my car and
they take my best friend to jail they
take him to jail
and then when they id her they find out
that she's missing she's been missing
so me not thinking because i'm so high
and i'm never
i haven't been to sleep so i'm
delusional i'm like what do you mean
like why are you taking him this is my
girl and whatever not they were just
like well either we take her or we take
you and i'm like why would you take her
and they were like well she's 17 years
old
and i'm like well take her then like i'm
not gonna go to jail so they take her
and so she hits me up and tells me i'm
all
i'm messed up that she she's being raped
by her her dad
and that i need to come get her well i
can't come get you
so i leave her where she's at so i end
up building my best friend out and we're
in his garage and
i get a phone call from the girl and she
tells me like oh i need you to you to me
meet up with me i got money for you and
all this now me i'm so money hungry and
so delusional
i go so when i go over there we're
talking
and i fall into her trap that you know
like i started answering questions that
i shouldn't have answered
like she asked me why did i do it to her
i told her because
i needed the money why did i beat her
why did i make her have sex with eric
and i'm like i didn't have you have sex
with eric you chose to have sex with
eric for some money
so she was she she set me up and
all i know is what came she was a woman
she was an informant
she was an informant and i got put on
long beach in
rosecrans at mcdonald's they swarmed up
on me and
they took me to jail so i'm fighting
i'm i'm in jail fighting pimping and
pandering
human trafficking um kidnap
in false imprison impersonation and rape
so they're trying to give me 65 a life i
won't take the deal
so then they tell me 25 to life i'm
definitely not taking the deal
or do you want to go to trial no because
i know
i'm going to lose because there's some
things that did happen and didn't happen
so then they gave me 16 with half no 16
with
life i told them no then they told me 16
would have
fine you know so i took 16 with half and
um in february um 2017
i ended up going up to chachilla in
print to prison
for pimping and pandering pimping and
pandering human trafficking
a female a female tim a female pimp so
well i'm in charge the first day in
chatella
i the first day i got off the bus i ra
um
i had girls at my door three girls ready
to fight me
so i got jumped i didn't lose you know
but i got jumped because
they said pretty girls are not allowed
to be in the yard
because they don't want their girls
which are either transgenders or
studs trying to hit on us so i got
jumped
for being pretty so from that day i
started doing drugs
and i started making shanks um
i got caught and i went to shu which is
acid lock up
24 out of seven lockers like solitary
confinement yeah i was in solitary
confinement
for six months and then when i got out i
started fighting just every day i went
over the i went over the wall to the
main yard
and i started just fighting everybody
everybody like every day it was non-stop
fighting
like i had scratches i had like bald
spots in my hair
like it was just that's why my face is
like so like
i have dark marks because i was fighting
every day
so i ended up it was to the point where
i
i hated people and i didn't i didn't
stop
like every day was fight for me so one
day this girl that was always bullying
me since
reception um i had enough for her so
every time i seen her it was
it was a fight on site like i would go
to her school i will
i will go to her school beat her up i'll
go into her room beat her up i'll go to
child
beat her up i would like everything
until she started pressing charges on me
and i ended up with an assault and
battery recharge so here goes more time
so they pushed me from 2021 all the way
to 2026.
so so now i'm in solitary confinement
again and
i'm here for eight months so from after
solitary confinement the girl calls
enemies on me
so i have to go to another prison when i
go to ciw which is california institute
for women in
corona i meet my girlfriend
and when i meet my girlfriend um she
tells me like she's not going to put up
on my [ __ ]
that she doesn't need she needs me to go
home before you know before time
so i did everything that i was supposed
to i sobered up i started going back to
college
i started getting i started working i
started working out
i started behaving myself and i got my
time back to may
2021. well my best friend that was
there at the time she was a drug addict
and
you know i got back on on it because
you know being in a room with her i got
back on my drugs
so now i'm i'm trying to keep it like oh
i'm not on drugs but i
am on drugs you know like trying to keep
it away from the police so and trying to
hide it and it got so hard that i just
passed out
so i asked them to put me back in walker
which is the
um the mental institution and
um because i try to commit suicide
because i just couldn't take it no more
like i was tired i was i was frustrated
like everything
like was coming down on me like i was
just breaking down little by little by
little and i try to kill myself i try to
hang myself
and i didn't go through with it so i was
in walker for three months
and they finally let me back out and
when they let me out they told me i was
gonna go to padding
so either i got my stuff back together
and get on my medication or
or i will go to patents so i got back um
i got back on my
my medication and i did my time and i
got out may 2nd
well when i got out to may 2nd they put
me here at the weingarten
when i got here to the weingarten
immediately i
became a fiend again um
huh you've only been out a short time
yeah i've only been out for a few weeks
and i got back on drugs like i'm
addicted i'm
i'm an addict like the drugs don't do me
i do the drugs
but i'm a fiend like i love drugs i love
the way it makes me feel
crystal meth yes i love the way it makes
me feel like it makes me feel like i
don't have a cure in the world
and i don't like i carry my pokey
everywhere with me and it's just
i don't care like i gave up gang banging
and i'm here at this program trying to
get my life together
yet i'm still getting high and
are you bad are you back to the
prostitution um i'm back at prostitution
i'm
i'm pimping and pandering again i'm
looking
i can't even lie i'm i am looking for
girls but in a different way like i'm
not trying to do
things i used to do the same way i'm
just trying to do it more
in the as an escort service instead of
prostitution
so yeah like i'm a hustler i love money
like my name is cash for a reason
so i'll get it anyway i can
i do it any way i can and you can't stop
me i'ma get money the way i can
and that's just me i'm 27 years old i'm
young i have no kids
and i'm gay and i'm a pimp like it can't
get no better than that
like girls love me like why not you know
so that's my life and you told me you're
a version as well and i'm a virgin
i'm a 27 year old version you've been
molested by your
i've been molested but in my eyes i
haven't gave myself up
oh i see i haven't said yes so in my
eyes i'm a version
whether they took it or not in my eyes
i'm always going to be a virgin
until i'm ready to go ahead and be like
all right take it
one day maybe i want kids so it might be
soon
i'm glad you're playing the game a
little smarter than you were before yes
of course
i'm not sure it's it's not it's not
smart but it's smarter or smarter yes i
mean
it's hard out here kovic it's like it's
hard to get a job out here nowadays
it's hard to get your social it's hard
to get your w what's your view on on
taking a girl a young girl and putting
her to work and
well okay so that was okay so when i was
doing my sister
i was she told me either i do it with
her like
either i pimp on her or she was gonna go
to someone else this is the same sister
that would that
was blessed by my grandfather and i
helped her out so why not
she's going to do it anyway she's going
to do it anyways so why not look after
her and with her
it wasn't like i was like oh go out
there [ __ ] like no
i had her and i was in the room with her
while she was doing her dates i was
there
protecting her now with everyone else i
didn't give a [ __ ] i didn't give a [ __ ]
like if they went to jail i didn't give
a damn
like that's you guys you guys chose to
do this with her i was there every step
of the way
you know and so she ran away and i was
like all right cool i don't have to
worry no more
and i started really like pimping but
i do feel bad and how is your
arrangement they bring you the money
i collect the money before they do their
date like i wasn't i was one of their
pimps that it was like all right
hand over the money i'm a girl like
they're not going to tell me no like you
know
so they're not worried about me and do
you give them
i give them yes i give them their cuts
yes i do i make sure they're they're
well groomed
i make sure they have clothes i make
sure their hygienes are fine i make sure
their doctor's appointments are great
i make sure they're just they're they're
natural they're
bomb [ __ ] like they're i never had
them looking like
hoes on fig aurora or like just
stragglers i never had them looking like
that
they were a1 like they couldn't be in
casinos like they were always online
and when they wanted to get down and on
the blade they got down on the blade by
themselves
i didn't force them i always had their
trap made when they were doing it online
so they were really escorts but i didn't
mess up by having a minor
and i do regret it because i should have
been smarter than that because that is
somebody's child
you know but i did not force her she
came willingly
so that i don't regret but i do regret
like
putting her through the stuff i put her
through and getting yourself in trouble
and getting myself in trouble
yeah so what what have you learned from
all this
you're still young you're 27 yes i've
learned that i can't trust people
the way i thought i could i'm not i
can't
be loyal to people that i used to be
because back then i was loyal like i
gave everybody everything
i gave you my last i go give you my
shirt on my back
if you needed it nowadays i'm like [ __ ]
you i got the [ __ ] it's i don't care
like you can be dying you could be
burning out there and i wouldn't piss on
you like
literally like i have no care in the
world nobody gave a damn about me i did
i did eight years by myself in prison
nobody there for me
but my girlfriend so i had to plug it
out by myself and now i got the [ __ ]
so i don't care
like i don't care about you and i'm not
going to jail for you or for nobody else
like if i'm going to go to john i'm
going to go to jail for something
serious
and that's just that and my life i'm
just going to i'm going to live it
i'm going to go back to school yeah i'm
i'm on drugs but
i know how to do stuff legally now now i
know
i have a i know my limit i'm not unsure
i'm not on heroin i'm not on all that
kind of stuff i'm just on
crystal and weed that's that
all right cash cash cash
thank you so much for talking with me
and i wish you the best of luck be
careful out there
thank you so much thank you very much
you